hi
um okay so so my title is an approach to
this line scale conjecture
uh from parallel position for
logarithmic testing so the standing
conjecture
is my favorite problem in in a classical
took over protocols it's a problem that
has been opened for um
for the past 20 something years and and
i really think that this is this is the
next problem we should solve
uh in this area
and in this talk i'm going to tell you
about some ideas about how to solve this
problem
and now of course the actual title is an
approach to the quantum
slang scale conjecture
scott tells me that this is how quantum
computer uh looks like
um
but my first the first step in my
approach is that you know if you want to
solve the the quantum cycle conjecture
we better solve the classical one
first
um
okay
so so what's the what's a conjecture
it's a conjecture that was formulated by
bilali godvass or london russell in 93.
and so we talked about about the pcb
theorem about about multiple protocols
and the theorem right theorem is that
all the languages in np have
have uh you know two pover protocols
multiple particles with constant number
of powers they look like that there is a
verifier
that tries to get convinced that
you know some formula satisfiable or
some other um you know np complete
problem
um
and it interacts with with two powers or
constant number of favors
it tosses some coins it uses them to
generate small questions to the two
provers
and it gets
answers from the two provers
very small very short answers much much
shorter than
you know the entire huge um weakness
not huge but the weakness of of uh
um
you know the the satisfying assignment
to your to your phone or whatever
um and and even though it only got this
very short replies the fact that it got
them from from two competing
to uh not communicating poovers is
enough to verify at least
probabilistically that that uh
the formula is desirable whatever other
np problem you were interested in
okay
now so so this is the the standard pcp
theorem and the
conjecture says that if the verifier
uses our random beats then its error
probability
should be two to the minus omega r right
so so whatever probability the the
understanding here is that if you know
the formula is satisfiable then there is
a strategy for the provers that uh the
valid file always accepts
on the other hand if the if the formula
is not satisfiable then for any strategy
for the provers the the total has some
small probability of saying you know
it's okay even though it's not okay
that's the l probability
and two to the minus r seems like
uh the the right the right number there
the right function there uh it's
definitely the the smallest number that
we can hope for right if we have our
random b
so you know why why not get two to the
minus r so that's that's a conjecture
that you can achieve minimal error yeah
so let me let me talk a bit about the
parameters here so what what what are we
talking here about so so developer uses
our random bits and then
the only thing that the poolers don't
know is what are the random beats so we
don't need question size you know the
number of bits that the the verifier
sends the provers you know more than
more than r it will usually be around r
so so the question size here should be
understood as is
r
now what about the the what the provers
sent back to the verifier
so we want to achieve our epsilon
and
one can show that the best error that we
can hope
uh if we have alphabet
alphabet say sigma uh the answer is like
answer size
the error can at best be one over sigma
squared why because one of the sigma
like sigma squared is the number of
possible things that the verifier can
see
okay and right so this is the resolution
that you're
talking here about
so so there is this um
like
polynomial uh relation between the
alphabet size and and the error
at best and and the answer size is the
is the number of beats you know in a an
alphabet symbol right so it's
logarithmic in that so the right
trade-off here is
is that the answer size and number of b
to the power stand back is logarithmic
in one over epsilon right in an ideal
um
scenario
and let me say that it's interesting in
general because we have this this
trade-off between the answer size
and the error
um
one may
also be interested not not necessarily
the minimal error but in other errors in
between and then get
lower answer size accordingly and this
is why this conjecture is known as the
sliding sky conjecture
however if we pull this conjecture for
the minimal error we have techniques to
go to any error in between
with with lower alphabet okay
um
yes so let's let me denote by sigma the
the number of possible answers that
poovers each of the poovers may send
okay so so the the exercise is log sigma
okay
so
they'll just signal to squared
different things that the verifier can
see
right and if not just sigma squared
then the error can't be better than than
than one over sigma squared right you
can just you can just guess a trend of
answers guess like the prover the the
poover is just like guess something at
random and um
if we want to show an algorithm that
simulates that we just guess at random
we're going to uh the developer is going
to accept with probability at least one
over sigma square right so epsilon has
to be at least one over sigma squared
and that's why the answer side which is
log
that is logarithmically
so that's the trade-off that we expect
uh notice that for the minimum error we
expect the answer size to be about r
just like the question
okay
um and and usually the randomness that
we care about when you talk about np is
logarithmic in in n and is the input
size and the reason is that
we want this
this transformation to still keep us in
in np right if the if r is logarithmic
then if i want to uh write down all
possible
questions and all possible answers of
the provers on any possible randomness
string i just need two to them to the
the
um
are
beats
and if or is the gradient to the r is
polynomial and i can just write down the
the strategy of the pulvers and this
becomes like a deterministic standard np
um weakness
for statistical ability okay so
so that's why we care about logarithmic
randomness so we keep everything in np
okay any questions
about the background yes what's the
reason for the name it's the lighting
skills because of epsilon that slides
right and and then the alphabet is
slides accordingly
um okay
so
it's really scaling between and the
exercise right again yes however
what
run in the city with you fixing the log
n yes yes
yes that's exactly the siding but let me
say that that from now on i'm only going
to concentrate on the minimal error
because if you solve the minimum error
you solve you can interpret between the
minimum ware and and up
we have techniques for doing that so so
we really just care about getting the
the lowest possible error
okay
good so so this was this was the
background
why do we care about this
this conjecture
um
we can't because
so one big motivation is is hardness of
approximation
um
so
though many there are many problems
that
you know the right answer for how hard
they are to approximate is is polynomial
uh hardness factors
um
so problems like max csp constraints and
inspection problems these are you have
variables you have constraints each
constraint depends on just constant
number of variables and you want to
satisfy as many constraints as possible
by assigning the variables accordingly
there is directed multicast for examples
we have sources and things and you want
to cut between them so you cut all each
pair
and it's a directed graph
and you want to
you know cut as still as possible
and there is closed vector problem in in
lenses
uh there are a bunch of problems like
that where
we think that the right answer is that
they'll be hard to approximate within
polynomial factors
and and we don't know how to prove it
and the reason we don't know how to
prove it is because we haven't solved
this lifestyle conjecture yet
um however if we do solve it we will get
those and and very likely we'll get many
more so so candidates here or the
shortest vector problem in lattices
uh clique um
right shop exactly sharp thresholds for
for consensus inspection problems on
smaller alphabet and so on and so on
um so
the
bunch of really great open problems
there just to understand what are the
implications of the steinstein
conjecture um yeah
so that's a good question that's uh
we i think that the answer is yes but
um
if you're interested in in working on
this uh it's a it's a great open problem
it's
something that i want to work
on but yeah i think the answer is yes i
think that it's really it's really
necessary
uh for those problems
okay
um
fine so
right it's a problem we really want to
solve um
and of course there was a lot of
you know interest in in solving it like
obviously when you care about
multiple over
uh games you want to get the low that
they are low right this is the first
thing you want to do about with with
the pcp theorem
and so there was a lot of effort in this
in this um
direction and let me tell you a bit
about this effort in in this direction
and
um
why will still far from actually proving
this like that conjecture
so the first time the pcp film was
pulled 92 um they showed constant error
okay like if it was with two powers that
was there it was like 0.9999
um and
this conjecture
actually came right after that in 93
that
obviously the right answer should be 2
to the minus r
but then we had all these years of
research
and we we know a lot much more than we
knew then but but still not that
so in 94
round pulled the power of repetition
theorem
and this gave this um
took over game
where the randomness was logarithmic
times log one over epsilon okay so what
we would want is the alphabet the
randomness is logarithmic and
the error is is um is polynomially
small
but here we have if we want
error which is which is one over n then
the randomness becomes square like log n
squared
okay
um
good so
it's not the right trade-off but it does
let you get
you know so usually the way it's used is
you can get any constant error you want
uh with logarithmic randomness
okay
then the works that said you know
why cal you know sure twofold versus the
most interesting
um
case this is the thing that is most the
the
field and the conjecture is most useful
for for hardness of approximation
um but if we increase the number of
poovers say to five we can actually get
there
uh to be lower
and a bunch of works um algebraic works
that manage to get the l down to two to
the minus r to you know some constant
third
um
but five five folders
uh and then still not right we don't
want this constant there because of this
constant we can't prove
good enough hardness of approximation we
need the constant in the exponent the
constant exponent
um then there was a photo of work by
elite and ran and mulisafra and guy and
doug fisher
and
they showed that you could push the
previous result even further
if you're willing to increase the number
of provers from you know some small
constant to
putting one over alpha you can get error
which is two to the minus r to the one
minus alpha
what is the exact effect of the increase
in the number of printers
the
those things will follow
this will not follow
like we we actually want to perverse to
proverbs is going to have many more
applications just the constant number of
provers already has many applications
we have this uh this framework based on
you know longhorn and
the mouth and these sort of things
works really well when you have two
pulvers on projection and doesn't work
very well when we have
a larger number of overs
wait so so you also need projection for
the yeah
i really need projection here so right
the ultimate pcp theorem is to prove it
just with with two pulvers and from you
know the answer of one poover you you
can also reduce the answer of the adult
over
but
already the case of constant number
fours has as important application
implications
okay
um
fine
right you can increase the number of
hovers get the get the error um even
lower pretty close to to the minus r but
still not the right exponent
um
then in 2008 with iran we managed to get
to two provers to the case that is
really uh interest to
to hardness of approximation
with randomness which is really minimal
randomness well the the constant is
before the logan is one
um
and the the only problem really
with this result was that the size the
answer size was poly one over epsilon
itself logarithmic and one over epsilon
uh and that's that's the reason that
this doesn't prove the cytosky
conjecture
and then recently
and david managed to
improve this a little by applying prior
partition
to this thing and and
they know how to analyze it and they can
get
the says a bit lower so so you can get
um
any so so okay so the meaning of this
you know one could think of that as you
can get error which is any like one over
log n to some constant and still have
polynomial
alphabet size
um so here you can get any poly
logarithmic uh
polygonally small error and still have
polynomial output size but you lose
the the
small randomness
so this is where we stand
with with uh error in in pcp with top
overs we have poly logarithmically small
error with more powers we have
to do the minus r to a constant rather
than two to the minus r
okay
and
you know my point here is that it's
about time to get two to the minus r
at least for full constant number of
powers
okay so so that's the previous work
and
and
so let's move on
you know in all those previous works
there were actually two approaches to
how to get low air for uh to prove your
games
and there was the
one it was the algebraic approach this
is the the approach based on on low
degree polynomials and logarithmic
testing which which i'm going to talk
about in the rest of the talk
and this is a great approach because it
gives you something structural that is
you know extremely strong
um
it tells you that if the veritas accept
with with pretty good probability it
means
that you know the proof that you see is
actually very close to a low degree
polynomial
um
this is you know something pretty
amazing that you can say something about
the proof that you see
and then you know big parts of it just
by knowing that the the test passes with
good probability so this is what i mean
by strong structural result
um the only problem with this support is
that the error
inherently in all those words was never
low enough it could never give the the
sliding sky conjecture
so this was this was one direction the
other direction was the combinatorial
direction based on on power repetition
and then the idea is that
you know you get some pcp we don't worry
about there it's going to have higher
and then you amplify the error by by
repeating
um
the the game
and this is this combinatorial uh
operation with all kinds of
analysis uh based on information theory
based on
on linear algebra
and and so on
the only problem with this is that
inherently uh the the
you know you saw that the the randomness
blows up right the randomness was log n
times log one over epsilon and one could
ask whether this has to be the case and
five and killian gave a pretty good
argument for why in
many interesting natural scenarios it
actually has to be the case that the
randomness is logan and times look one
over epsilon
and so it cannot give the sliding scale
conjecture
so
so this was this was the situation um
the speed and that's the reason that we
haven't gotten this dinosaur conjecture
so far
and what i suggest in this work is as an
approach to how to get this lengthy
conjecture
and the approach is
well let's do everything algebraically
but let's apply power repetition on it
so we finally have an algebraic test
where uh the error is low enough okay so
we gain this like really strong
structural result but with error that is
you know the right error
so so that's the approach
um and the hope
is that unlike
this repetition the the perpetration in
that right setting would be uh
derandomizable
um unfortunately i don't know yet how to
de-randomize it and i'm going to talk
about
what kind of problems are involved in
randomizing it
um
so i don't have a pool for the science
style conjecture
um
but but maybe
maybe you would
okay
so let's talk about polynomials and log
degree testing and like what what comes
into you know algebraic proofs of the
pcp theory
okay
so so here is here's the game
uh i have three parameters f is a finite
field
m is some dimension i'm going to look at
the space f to the m
and these are some degree it's some uh
natural number much smaller than the
than the field size but usually it's
still pretty big
um
and
i have two covers and the proverb
supposedly met ahead of time and agreed
about some agreed on some uh low degree
point no and some polynomial of the
great was these over f to the m in you
know m variables over the field
and
supposedly whenever the value file asks
them about this polynomial they the
answer about this polynomial
um
however the the valid file doesn't trust
them they'll provers um and they may
answer different things that that are
not what they're supposed to not the the
you know so supposedly if the they
decide about the polynomial and the
validifier asks them about uh the
evaluation of the polynomial point this
is what they'll
this is what they'll give but but maybe
they want and developer wants to check
that they actually do so here is
something that the the belly file can do
uh it can
pick a point completely at random form
after vm
and then pick two lines random lines
through x okay and one to the first over
and one for the second pulver and then
ask the provers you know give me the
restriction of the polynomial that you
decide about ahead of time to this line
okay so
they're both supposed to answer
and they're supposed to answer with a
univariate polynomial of degree at most
d right because the restriction of a
point of degree that mostly in every
variable to a line is that we know in
one variable um
of degrees mostly so they they answer
that uh to the verifier and then the
verifier
just checks
that the two um
the two polynomials actually agree on
the point the two lines have in common
right so this way the verify both checks
consistency between the answers of the
two polynomials of the two powers um
and it checks low degree because you
know those p1 and p2 are polynomials of
flow degree
and the hope is that if they you know
obviously if they uh answer according to
this one polynomial that they had in
mind then this test will always be fine
will always right the velcro will always
extend
but the hope is that if the verifier
accepts many times it really means that
they agreed on 1.0 and keep
keep answering accordingly
right because if they keep answering you
know inconsistent polynomials then you
know those polynomials are going to
differ
um
a lot and we're going to catch them okay
so that's the hope behind this
this line versus lying test
yeah um for you you're checking that
yes
okay
good so that's that's the the line
versus line test and and
after so there was a lot of research on
this thing it wasn't initially uh
suggested by by
byrob benefits and sudan and even women
in sudan
the whole thing started with this uh
paper of belarus um
belarus and rubenfeld
about linearity testing
so everything becomes much much easier
if you talk about instead of degree d
polynomials you talk about
one polynomials like linear functions
so
the research started on that and then
advanced to to
multi-linear polynomials and then
advance to
the great d polynomials uh each time it
gets harder but but each time
the the advantage is that you have
uh more code words right you have more
degree polynomials then you have linear
functions and therefore if you try to
use these as an encoding
um
you need you need fewer beats
um
so this gives like lower length
um or lower randomness
uh for the verifier
so there was a huge amount of research
on this sort of
test
and this is the the state of the art by
by sanjiva and madusudan in 97.
and they say that as long as the the
field is sufficiently large with respect
to the degree and to the dimension
if the the this test languages line
passes with probability at least gamma
gamma is you know any natural number
any real number that you want between
zero and one
then there must exist a polynomial of
degree at most d global polynomial in n
variables
um that agrees with
at least
about grammar fraction of all plants
so this is this
amazing amazing theorem
right so it's enough that the the
verifier accepts with good probability
to know that
what the what the two provers are saying
is actually
um
you know looks in many places like
the green d polynomial
and really the loss that we have here we
started with this
probability of passing gamma and we have
here gamma minus about one over f
this is really the the
the best loss that you could hope for
because if you think about it
you know suppose that the proverbs don't
don't work according to any one low
degree point no one suppose they just
give you uh their answers completely at
random it's some random universe points
of the great mostly
so
the probability that you have
consistency where you just have two
random values right the evaluation of
the of the
of the
pulling each of the polynomials
on each of the points is just like a
random
field element and the probability the
two random field elements are the same
is one over f
right so
even if the provers don't do anything
that's that is actually like a low
degree polynomial they still succeed
with probability one over f
so so you have to have this sort of uh
loss here
and they still um you know so the
constant is tells you that this is the
loss you actually have
other than that if you have uh the
acceptance probability much larger than
one over f
then it's actually a low degree
polynomial that is that that responding
funny
okay
so that's the this amazing theory
and let me answer
uh thomas's question
so here is the first point i want to
make
if we want to solve this lying sky
conjecture
it's enough
to just completely concentrate on this
problem flow degree testing we can
forget about you know sat and protocols
like general you know multiple protocols
and so on and so on we can just think of
this low degree testing problem
and the only thing we need to do is to
get a low degree test well the
randomness is is end times look right
it's this is the randomness that you
have for
line versus line right you just pick a
constant number of points in f2 dm it's
this is
the randomness
you have constant number of queries or
constant number of provers
um
if you have this and error which is f to
the minus m like error which is
polynomially small in the space that
you're walking on
walking over
then you get the slang cell conjecture
so uh people who are
experts in algebraic techniques in in
pcp
are not surprised
by by this
lemma
uh right it's essentially uh
well known um and and the way it's
proved is you say well start with with
any
you know pcp theorem
and then take your pcp proof and encode
it with a low degree polynomial
and what's the advantage of low degree
polynomials it's that there are very
good locally decodable codes
and
you know you you have the log degree
test and you'll use the law of the v
test to make sure that that what's
written is actually essentially a low
degree polynomial
and then you use the fact that the the
logarithmic polynomials are
great locally decodable codes in order
to
decode things from
the um
the original pcp proof and simulate kind
of a
sequential repetition um
version of the of the original pcp
so that's that's how the the proof goes
um
so to adapt it to uh this setting of
parameters you have to walk a little
um
so
it does involve a different setting of
parameters than
uh
one usually has in those things you
start with a different pcp theorem then
you usually start with
um
to pull this i actually
went and and pulled like a
combinatorial composition that wasn't
written anywhere before so
right it's a bit
somewhat
right there is work that gets into
proving this but
at least for the experts this is not
this is known yes so what's the best
thing that we know in the current uh
literature
what i had before right the best thing
we know is to have error which is one of
the less
and i want the same parameters but with
l1 over left to the m
that's a lot right
and and and
yeah
but what i'm going to show you in this
work is how to get error which is one
over to the m
this is the the result the only thing is
that
you're going to play the randomness
instead of the randomness being m log f
the randomness is going to be m squared
look f
which
you know is not what we want
but if you manage to do what i can do
without blowing up the randomness
without the randomness being n squared
log f but just m log f
you pull this line skull conjecture
okay
any questions before i move on to
how we do that yes yeah i'm slightly
confused about pcp and going to prove
our proofs because for me it's it looks
like what you're doing to be an improver
interactive proof yeah but you said
pcp earlier and i thought pcp is
one prover produces a string of bits and
i look at uh small subsets of this so
probably there's some relation
but in the classical world they're
completely equivalent
and what is the number of provers then
the number of quarters is the same as
the number of course
ah okay approval is a priority yes
yes
okay but a completely equivalent it
doesn't matter of you know saying things
differently and if you want to see the
equivalence exactly we can talk about
at least i have an idea what the
direction is
okay
um
good
so
here is here is the idea
right which i already said before i just
want to do per repetition of
of low degree testing
right
right so so line versus line before it
just could never get an error which is
better than one over f just because two
random elements in the field you know
agree with probability like one graph
so the obvious thing is that instead of
checking just one point instead of doing
just one comparison i need to do many
comparisons
right so say okay prime comparisons this
is the parameter i'm going to use
so that's that's the obvious idea
and what i want to describe to you now
is is how
you would still do a low degree test um
kind of
you still have an algebraic structure
but you uh
check
not just one point by but you know many
points okay
and
so what we'll see is that it's actually
tricky how you define parallel petition
follow the re-testing i'm going to show
you now the most natural formulation
and the problem is going to be that this
formulation makes no sense it looks good
but then it's completely trivial
and i'll show you why and then i'll show
you how one can fix it and and
why we
we have a bit of a solo definition of a
repeated test okay but let's let's do
the natural thing first we have two
provers we want to check not just one
point but many points but but still have
this algebraic structure
so
the benefit is going to
pick at random k prime points
and it's going to pick two curves for
those k prime points
and it's going to send each curve to the
to each poover and it's going to get
answers
and
so this should be degree d k prime
um and the two answers i'll you know
supposedly the restrictions of this
polynomial of the gradient mostly that
they had in mind
to the the curves that they got oh i'm
sorry it is decay because the
i'm denoting the the the degree of the
curves by k
and and i'm thinking of k which is
slightly larger than k prime uh but but
around the same
the same order of magnitude
um so so they gave me the restrictions
the supposed restriction to the to the
curves
and then
i can check not just one intersection
point by the k prime intersection points
that they have
so i check that for every i
the two polynomials agree on on x i
right
so
in my mind this is a natural
generalization of perpetration to low
degree testing
the only thing is that something very
weird happens here
not only this doesn't improve the
soundness of the test it actually
makes the soundness of the test worse
okay and let me let me show you that
and then more gently instead of curves i
can i can have surfaces
which
is
nice and i think will be useful for the
randomization but
let's go with curves for now
so the thing is that now the provers
have a larger intersection
and in the setting of testing they can
actually use the larger intersection
they have to cheat
and here is what what they'll do
they're going to decide ahead of time
pump point x in f to the m
about a polynomial p
subscript x completely different random
polynomial
associated with the point
and the polynomial is going to be of the
gradient the issue is that there are
going to be lots and lots of polynomials
like that one vote for each point
and what the provers are going to do so
they get
two surfaces yes one and s2
and they're going to write down the the
the points that
in each of the circuits and then
let's say that they decide ahead of time
on some random permutation of the points
in f to the n and they're going to sort
the the points they got according to
this permutation
now they're going to take the smallest
point
among the ones they got
according to the permutation
and they're going to answer the
restriction of p of the smallest point
to the to the surface they got
okay so this is the the prover strategy
okay and i claim that this proverbs
strategy actually
makes them uh
succeed with good probability even
though you know this is not
any one low degree polynomial actually f
to the m law degree polynomials here and
an f to the m right is this huge
um
so
how do you see that
well look at those points that the the
the over profiles got and let's
now for the sake of analysis salt all of
them together
okay
now when are they going to be consistent
they're definitely going to be
consistent
if
the smallest point
among all of the points that they got
is in the the intersection between the
two surfaces
right because each one answers about the
smallest point that they got
obviously the smallest point everywhere
if it's in the intersection it's going
to be the smallest here and the smallest
here
right
and in this case i'm going to be exactly
consistent
but the issue is that this happens with
probability which is the the
intersection between the surfaces
divided by the the the uh
union of the two surfaces
and this you know if we think of this as
about f
and the intel section is now instead of
being just one point escape fine
points so
we actually have like pretty good
probability of being consistent
without having any polynomial here right
larger probability than before
okay
so
while this test kind of makes a lot of
sense
it just
in the context of testing it's terrible
it just makes everything worse instead
of amplifying everything
okay
any questions about this argument
so the line versus line case
you have a one in the numerator yeah
but then when the intersection is larger
larger they use the larger intersection
to actually increase the probability
okay so luckily there is a
very nice idea of
it had a somewhat related paper paper
that kind of inspired this paper
not about polynomials but about that
product testing
but they had the same the same problem
there
and they
noticed
that if you just
add one proverb
then you can
just avoid the problem that i just
mentioned
so so what will we do we have still
probably a and b but then we'll add a
new proverb over ba and proof of bi is
acts like purple b for puffer and
actually purple a for provel
b right this is the the puffer in the
middle and what i'm going to do is
instead of just doing one
test
i'm going to do two tests
kind of in parallel but with with
those different sets of provers
so developer is going to pick k prime
points but it's also going to pick
another completely random completely
independent k prime type of point
it's going to generate one surface
from one random surface to those to
provel a another surface
through those two pool b and another
surface put those
to prover uh this is called the a and
another over b
and the point here
is that
pool ba has intersection has k-prime
intersection both with provo a and with
pulver b but those intersections are
independent
i'm just randomly
independent okay
so why why does this solve the problem
so what happened before was that the
provers had this like user intersection
and they used intersection to to
coordinate answers even though they
didn't make any global polynomial
but now provel a and provo b
you know have nothing in common
right they're just like random curves
through like completely random k prime
taffles so they don't have an
intersection they can use to their
advantage
and they can't coordinate
and if over ba tries to play the
original protocol
then it has two completing goals on one
hand it tries to be consistent
with a on the other hand it tries to be
consistent with provel b
but then it has to be to give one like
low degree polynomial here
and
it just it's just torn right and it just
can't do do that
so that's the that's the intuition
um
okay
and indeed so this is this is my
definition of a power repetition of law
degree testing okay
and indeed what i'm able to show is that
if i have parameters such that this like
myself as versus surface has error which
is about one over f you know like client
versus line
then the repeated test actually has
error you know one over f to the k
right the number of comparisons we make
right which is the the result that we
expect right because we started with
with the test with probability of r one
over f so here we and we do k prime
repetitions we expect one over f
k prime
all right
um
so so that's the theorem i'm able to
prove in this work parallel petition
follow the re-testing
now
i should say that
right it's it's not it's not uh
trivial to pull such a theorem uh write
file repetition is
pretty difficult and say per repetition
runs for prayer repetition
um
even if it starts with with a test with
a really low error
it only has the the repeated test would
only have error which is two to the
minus k prime
other than you know the oh that you
started with to the to the k prime
um
and then the recent work of of elite and
and david does have this property that
if you started with low air you still
have this lower in in the base but this
came after
you know
some years of research and it wasn't
clear how to do that in the beginning
uh for for testing which is you know you
have a stronger guarantee than the
normal pcpu you have this like
structural guarantee
actually much less was known
one could have those ikw techniques and
get error which is two to the minus
square root
k
so this is this is bad both in the base
that is not the right base and in the in
the exponent which is not the right
exponent
so actually one of the things that that
started this this work was that of the
videos when i came to princeton asked me
you know
can you actually get
instead of this quote k can you actually
get k there right can you can you get
parameters as good as like hans
parameters in the power
petition
and i
wasn't clear how to do that
okay
so
um
i don't have much time and
but luckily i'm not going to
show you the proof of the of the power
petition
but i do want to show you
a few things about this proof especially
i want to explain why we get improved
parameters
so a few of your remarks about the
repetition as i i kept saying it's not
the randomized it's fair repetition like
all of our power petitions which you
know we just pick everything completely
at random
and the big open problem is whether you
can de-randomize it
um so it improves the parameters of ikw
it also simplifies the the proof of ik w
um
and the nice thing is that unlike you
know
standard pair repetition it gives you
this very strong structural
guarantee that the proof is actually a
polynomial that this
strategy is actually a polynomial
and
not only it gives you this much stronger
ability but actually the proof itself
uses
this stronger guarantee
inside to make things easier
and
kind of the the the main reason that
we're able to um to improve over the
previous works
is that we have better kind of mixing
properties like expander extractor kind
of
stuff for
incidences incidents graphs the right
incident scraps
and this is what i want to show you
next i want to show you
why this comes into the proof
and what exactly we're able to show that
is that is new and gives this like f to
the minus
what
what is
at least
right the ikw techniques for this
problem would have given two to the
minus
square root k and and we give this
i don't actually have an improvement for
the dallas product
and i'm not going to discuss that
yeah so
so actually the result that they are
able to prove is 2 to the minus
k prime but only for k prime which is
most quote k
okay
so let me define incidence graphs
so
an incidence of this in this graph of
surfaces versus k tuples of coins
is the bypass of the gap
when on one side we have all the
surfaces that we consider um
maybe all the curves or the lines or
whatever and on the other side we have
all the k prime tuples of points in in
studio
and
um
right the standout like a light versus
point graph would be here you have lines
and here you'll have points and i'm
looking at this like more general graph
will you have surfaces versus cape line
table
and and you have edges if if you have
containment right
the points here are contained in the
surface there okay so that's that's
an incidence uh graph
and
so the entire point in in this
repetition proof is to say well we have
this strategy for how to win in this you
know uh
game on on when we compare k-prime
couples
um
but
really what we want to say is that we
can come up with uh with a strategy for
the base game
for the game where we only compare on uh
one point because on the base game we do
have a guarantee we know that that uh
that there is this structural thing if
the
the very fire accepts a lot then it will
get pretty normal
so
kind of the entire uh
point here is how to move
from this like whole strategy for the
surfaces to some strategy that that is
consistent on single points
here right so you're starting from the
strategy that's yes has very low error
on surfaces
all the way
yes
but the way it's uh yeah but it kind of
in the resolution that i'm going to talk
about i don't even
right the way you actually do that is
you say well let's look at surfaces that
pass
the test on
you know some smaller number of
points and then let's let's see whether
they they're going to pass the test on
another point and so on but
yes
um
okay
so um
let's look at the incidence graph let's
pick some points and let's look at the
incidence graph of you know let's look
at all look at all the surfaces for a
point x and all the k prime uh tuples
for the point x this is a sub graph
of the whole thing that is relevant to
so what do we think is the answer for uh
for point x
okay
and suppose that the strategy that the
provers
the pulverize peaked is actually is
terrible is that
it's not actually consistent on on
points on different points it gives
completely different
things right this is the thing that
we're really worried on we have the
strategy that doesn't correspond to
to actually repeating
a base strategy
so so suppose that this is the case and
kind of the main lambda in this proof
is that as long as this graph is like
really well mixing is a really good good
expander
you know if you have heel surfaces that
that you know each one gives give it
gives a completely different different
point
and then you do this test of taking two
surfaces that intersect in a k prime
type of point
so
it's not clear that you you're going to
you know detect the fact that they they
disagree because maybe
what you're asking is just on on
uh you're just asking surfaces that do
agree even though globally they don't
don't agree
but then the the main
observation is that if this graph is a
this extremely good expander that this
is not going to happen that if there is
an inconsistency and you compel surfaces
on on k prime tables itself on single
points
then you're going to detect this this is
called inconsistency
so the heart of this of this pool is to
show that this is an extremely good
expander
and the interesting thing is that
so so we have a technique to to analyze
the the
expanded focal piece of you know
surfaces versus points or curves versus
points or lines versus point so this we
have a great technique for and we do you
know ky's independence uh if the
surfaces of degree okay
and this is also what ikw do and it's a
it's a well-known technique
and the problem starts when instead of
looking at points you look at k prime
tuples of points then we don't we didn't
really have techniques
to 200k prime tables of points
and
what ikw did is just to generalize the
ky's independence argument to argue
instead of on single points to argue on
k-prime table couples of points
and that's why they have like really
weak parameters
and
then there was a question what to do
because
you know this seems like the like a
tight
thing to do
and then it turns out that that actually
it's not it's not the tight thing uh in
in our setting of parameters and what we
end up doing is the following
so consider the the graph that we do
know how to analyze which which has
surfaces versus points
um
okay
now we can view so suppose that we now
want to analyze the the graph of
surfaces versus pairs of points
so we can view
that surfaces versus pairs as a product
of surfaces versus points and surfaces
versus points
because there's a dotted product or a
very special direct product of grass
and the way we can do it is we can take
any point x and look at all the surfaces
through x and look at all the the you
know and then
like put here another copy of the big
graph
okay fill point
and and we do right suppose if we do
this for all points and then the new
graph that we get is surfaces versus
pairs
and what one is able to show i mean we
do it of course k-plane several times
what is able to one is able to show is
that the product of two
graphs graphic of mixing is mixing too
and
since the origin graph we knew that it
was mixing well then also um after we
just use this product again and again we
still have a graph that mix as well
does the mixing become
yes that what what
what deter rates we actually want like
an extractor here and what it tolerates
is the closeness to uniform and it's
multiplied by by
k prime which is actually the reason why
we don't get an improvement to the
original ikw
uh thing but but in our setting of
parameters this is perfectly fine
it's a very small deterioration
um
and then it turns out it turned out that
i wasn't the first to define this this
graph product it was actually defined in
the context of extractors and people
used it to get their extractors or
condensers
but
i think this is the first time that this
this idea is used for analyzing a
concrete interesting
graph
okay so
so that's the main reason why we're able
to to improve we get the optimal
parameters
uh for the expander from from the static
product argument
okay
um the big open problem is you know can
you deal randomized for repetition let
me briefly say that for no repetition
there is a spaghetti an argument
uh that that gives a very severe
limitation
um and
what
i would if i had
more than two minutes
um but i'm very happy to explain offline
so you know whoever is interested
uh it's a very nice very simple argument
um but it's very convincing
but the thing is that in this scenario
where you have three provers and two all
completely dependent and the third
checks consistency this limitation is
actually avoided
um as long as there is the two um
as long as the two intersections are
independent
uh this limitation is is actually
avoided
um
so
so that's that's open can you actually
be randomized for repetition
and and hence pull the sliding skull
conjecture
let me end
by suggesting a challenge problem
so this won't immediately give you
the randomized
uh you know law degree test five
petition
uh follow degree testing but
i think that this is the the health of
the
of the matter here and i think that if
if you manage to solve this i
i i feel like
getting the
very busy people there would be just
like a bit of pork
so here is the question
how there are two
small relatively small families of
surfaces and k prime tuples of points
such that
two incidence graphs are
mixed well one is the the incidence
graph of surfaces versus k-prime tuples
and the other is the incidence graph of
k prime tuples versus point
points and and this is my what i mean
concretely by
mixing well for each of those
incidence graphs this is
this says that del this is a good
sampler and this says that this is a
good disperser
um so it's standal definitions in in
into the randomness
um
but it basically means that you have
those
um set of surfaces that are you know
very well distributed over your space
but also the link of sections are very
well distributed over the the space
that's the
the algebraic question here equally the
intersecting surfaces
uh question and
i'll
please solve it
i've worked on it for like the past
i know two years
and and i have tried a lot
and i don't know how to solve it
as of now
that's it thanks
which has the randomizing power of
addition i think in the title or
something can you
explain is that at all relevant to this
algebra yeah so what they do there is
they
they say that if you apply this
extremely expensive transformation on
your original pcp and make it into a
linear
pcp
then
perpetition becomes easy
it's also there is this another
then then you can actually deal
randomized for repetition there's also a
similar paper of financial tier that
says that if you have perpetration of
three games well let me not define free
games uh then also uh
you could deal with a petition the issue
with both papers is that the
transformation to take a normal protocol
and convert it either to linear or auto
free
is very costly
so that's why it's unhelpful uh for the
size scale conjecture i think there's
also another issue
the error is polynomial in the number of
repetitions and not exponential
but the slightest
yeah you need it both to be exponential
and the base has to
factor in there and actually
it wasn't clear how to do that
yeah
can you say more about the quantum
version of
so the quantum version which i defined
now
um
is can you can the value file get
l 2 to the minus r when the two powers
are in
okay so so we have uh
like uh thomas and then suijito's
result
and they pulled the the basics uh pcp
theorem for integral powers and then the
question is
you know we don't want to basically want
lower
pcp with internet movers can you get
that
and i think that
other talks today may help you
think about
about that problem
on thursday because
i thought that today is the survey of
your
result no
no well
on thursday there's talks entirely with
edition in the quantities so okay we're
sort of asking what is the
fun version of this sliding scale
conjecture is still getting way ahead of
ourselves
so we're still sort of trying to figure
out the basics of
you know even
the most naive of the reputation so
basically
can you just summarize what's the
consequence of that quantum conjecture
hopefully the
right hopefully
i guess
right so
so i guess um
if you remove the classical like
motivation to almost approximation it's
just
can you do to prevent protocols because
of cryptography because of
right in the presence of entanglement
um
right and i think maybe shafi will talk
about applications to
um
okay so let's stop and
continue again